TODD KERPELMAN: Hello,
and welcome to "Route 85,"
our new show for
you iOS developers.
Thanks for coming.
Glad you could join us.
So for this episode, I
wanted to present you
with a quick tip that was shared
by Tom Van Lenten on the Google
Maps team.
Now I would love to call this
our tip of the week segment,
but I don't think I can
commit to making these videos
that often, so it's "Quick Tip."
And thanks to Tom
for sending it in.
So for this example, let's say
that I'm building a card game
app that uses standard
playing cards.
And within my
PlayingCard.h file I
decide to create an
enum for the suit.
So here we go.
Looks pretty normal
so far, right?
And down below, we'll
store this as a property.
Now let's say I wanted
to write a method
to do something
based on this suit.
Maybe different suits give me
different point multipliers
in our card game when we
get to the scoring section.
And so we'll need
to write a method
to convert these suits
into point multipliers.
Well, this seems like
a pretty obvious case
for a switch statement.
So we'll start to
type it in here.
We'll add in the
case for spades,
for hearts, diamonds, and clubs.
And then we get to this
default statement at the end.
And huh, well, what
should we do here?
I mean, gosh, I can't
think of a time we'd ever
get to this, right?
Like, we've got all of
our suits covered above,
so it seems like if
we get to this point,
something bad is going on.
But still, we should
code defensively, right?
So maybe we'll throw
an exception here.
I'm going to add the comment
"this should never happen."
and then right below,
we'll throw an exception,
because clearly our
game is in a bad state.
Well, anybody who's
worked in software
knows that simply adding the
comment "this should never
happen" to your code
magically ensures
that at some point in the future
that exact thing will happen.
So let's go back
to our card game.
And our lead designer
suddenly decides
we need to have
jokers in our game.
Well, jokers are going
to need their own suit.
And so maybe the engineer
assigned to this task,
well, they see that we need
to add a joker to our enum.
But our code base has grown
and maybe our engineer
doesn't notice that
the getPointMultiplier
method, among all of our other
code, also needs that enum,
so it doesn't get updated.
Well, what happens?
That's right.
We hit the default statement.
Our code raises an exception.
And the whole thing crashes.
Now, if you're
lucky, this will get
caught in testing
while in development.
If you're slightly
less lucky, this'll
get caught by Apple during
the approval process.
And if you're not
lucky at all, it
won't get noticed
until it starts
crashing on all of
your players, probably
at the time the press decides
to start reviewing your game.
Huh.
That's unfortunate.
So what can you do here?
Well, the answer might
be to do something
that seems a little
counter-intuitive at first.
I'm going to go and
remove this default block
from the end of our
switch statement.
I know it seems weird, right?
Like, I'm all nervous.
My immediate reaction is I
want to put that thing back.
But now look what happens
now that I have done this.
Xcode is warning
me before I even
run this thing that the switch
statement is now incomplete
and I might want to fix it.
It's smart enough to know that I
haven't covered all my options.
And it'll give me
this nice warning.
And in fact, in this
case, ha, no pun intended,
I not only get a
warning, but I also
get an error because
there are times
my method no longer
returns a float
and my app won't even build.
By the way, even better
if you're using AppCode,
hitting Alt-Enter will give
you this "create missing switch
cases statement," which
will automatically spec out
those missing code
branches for you.
That's pretty nice, huh?
Oh, and for you
Swiftees out there,
Swift is even more harsh.
It upgrades that
warning to an error.
And it won't let you
create any switch
statement that isn't exhaustive.
Of course, their
recommended solution
is to add a default clause.
But as we've seen, that
isn't always the best advice.
Now obviously you can't
do this in all situations.
If you're writing a switch
statement based on an integer
or say a text
character, Xcode won't
know whether you've covered
all these cases are not.
And in fact, in these
kinds of situations,
Xcode will complain
correctly that you
do need to add a default case.
But if your switch statement
is based on an enum
and you don't think that
default case should ever
happen, drop it and let Xcode
catch those errors for you
before your players do.
So there you go.
Thanks again to Tom on the
Google Maps for iOS team
for sending me the tip.
But what about you?
Do you have an
idea that you think
would make for good "Quick Tip"?
Send it in.
You can email me at
the address here.
If we use it on the air, I
will send you some schwag.
I'm not sure what
it's going to be,
maybe a t-shirt or a
key chain or an iPhone 6
or-- what's that?
I'm sorry.
OK.
I've been told we don't have
the budget for an iPhone 6.
But we do have the
budget for a t-shirt,
so maybe it'll be that.
Anyway, thanks for tuning in.
You keep coding.
And I'll see you next
time on "Route 85."